[Music]
mark is with us in nashville hey mark
how are you
good how are you dave better than we
deserve man
thank you what's up
hey um so uh we've been listening me and
my wife have been listening on your show
for the past six years and we're able to
pay off all our student loan debt and um
follow the baby steps and uh we kind of
got off the beaten path a little bit uh
recently and we uh
we bought a piece of land uh we live in
the nashville area
and um
we're kind of facing this decision uh
now
we want to be completely debt-free and
if we sell our house
and
and rent we we'd like to build a
property on or build a house on this
piece of land in the next three to four
years
we would be
we'd be able to pay off the rest of the
land and be completely
debt-free and
actually be able to save a little bit
more money per month
while renting
and
we were just kind of wondering if that
was a smart idea or
um i know there's just so much going on
with the real estate market in nashville
uh we're just not
sure what to do i have a really good
income um so we'll be able to save a lot
of money
in the next few years good what's your
income
anywhere from
230 to 250. excellent very very good
okay what's your house payment
uh like nine hundred dollars a month
no you don't sell your house you can't
rent cheaper than that
well we we have we have to pay money on
the land as well so yeah but you gotta
pay money on the land if you sell the
house and rent
right but we would be able to pay off
the balance of the land if we sold their
house
oh you'd get the equity out of the house
and do that okay so what are you all on
the land
uh we owe about 260 000 what do you owe
in your house
about 200
okay what could you sell the house for
about 500. okay
i would just sit right there dude i'd
sit right there and i would plow through
this land
as hard at the money at this land hand
over fist
and get it paid off and then start
talking about building a house on that
land
okay uh i guess we just um
we just feel like you know in in the
next three to four years like
if we sold our house it it would
it would take a lot of risk out of
everything if you want to sell it sell
it okay you don't need me to do that
okay but but right but you got to live
somewhere and you have a 900 house
payment on a house that's going up in
value while you're pulling off all these
other tricks
and you're abandoning both of those good
things
to go ahead and get the land paid off
that's what i wouldn't do
okay but you can do whatever you want to
it's obvious you you know
you make a lot of money you're doing
great none of these things are in the
stupid column it's just a matter of
which one is going to be the fastest
most expedient but i mean you priced
rent in nashville right
yeah we we uh in the area that we're
looking um
for the same size house would be about
2500 bucks a month yeah and i make about
20 000 a month
i know
what you make a month is a is the static
piece of information in either one of
these scenarios
but the the two things what we're
comparing against is 900 a month that
goes up in value or 2500 a month in the
middle of the table on fire
yeah
y'all just want out of debt is your
motivation mark for asking the question
because you guys just want to be pay
everything off and it just feels better
and then you're renting like is that
what you're is that what you guys are
feeling both of you
i guess it just feels more simple and
it just
because because i know that that
like you you say that the housing prices
are supposed to go up but there's a
chance also that they could go down and
i just feel like if you're going to sell
you want to sell now i think you're
making a mistake because you're you
really do think house prices are going
to going to go down and i think you're
wrong
especially in nashville mark right
i think you're wrong yeah
i think you've been hanging out with the
wrong people at the bar
oh my gosh
and they're all talking they're all
talking
your friends are all talking trash i
want to hear mark what you have to say i
really do because i hear the same thing
so go
for our specific scenario um you know in
the next three four years that
how much are it's like how much our
house is really going to go up and is
that worth the risk of
keeping it for that long what's causing
you mark to think that what's causing
you mark to think that your house price
is going to go down here in nashville
why why do you think that
i don't know that it's going to go down
but i don't know that the amount that it
will go up but why why are you coming to
these conclusions
give me like data give me a reason
because the uh the price of our houses
has more than doubled in the past six
years and i just i don't see that amount
of increase as a percentage of increase
i think i mean it may increase but i
don't know if that increase over three
to four years is going to be worth
the risk of us keeping
the house versus being out of debt the
risk
of the debt on the land
yeah like say that the debt on our our
house and the land
like if
say if something happened to my job or
something in the next three to four
years
it would be
pretty uh i don't know you could sell
either one or both of these properties
yeah yeah i guess i just worry about
if the demand will still if there's
still going to be the demand at the core
of all of this back and forth in your
verbal is you really don't you are
really worried that house prices are
going to go down you really do believe
there's a high probability they're going
to go down and that's at the core of
your question and that's why i think
you're wrong
okay now you can do what you want to do
there's no real downside except a little
bit of lost money on you selling your
house today
but so sell it today and go pay off your
land and go rent
but then go back and look when you
finish this transaction three years from
now and see what that house that you
sold did
and then we can determine if i was right
or not
but um
and mark let me say this though because
the marketing the market is softening it
is making people be like oh wow so yes
houses are going back to what they
actually are valued at and what
appraisal is coming in at
yes versus in nashville we all knew this
like three months ago i mean six nine
months ago
someone here at the office they got 56
offers over a weekend like and it was
like 200 over asking for i mean just you
hear the craziest stories you heard the
craziest choices you're not gonna have
that anymore so i think that's gonna but
that doesn't mean that the value of your
home is gonna tank because no supply is
not gonna catch up with demands here in
the near future and i think that and i
honestly do think that there are still
these areas around the country we talked
about this last segment
has 25 000 employees in downtown
nashville amazon has 25 000 employees
and the healthcare industry companies
you can't beg a house in nashville right
now because these huge corporations have
moved in here and made it their
headquarters okay and they're moving out
of new york they're moving out of
california and they're moving in here
and setting up shop because we're a tax
free income tax again if you are houston
mark if you were i mean another place
maybe we could have you know another
there's not in a market that's going to
crash dude now again if you want to do
this the only thing you've lost is
whatever you didn't make on your house
and so it's not a huge like there's
nothing nothing here in the stupid
column but what i what i want to teach
you and people listening is when you
make decisions based on feelings instead
of real data
on negative feelings fear
it almost never leads to good financial
consequences
and so at the core of your
concern at the core of your question is
a false assumption that real estate in
nashville tennessee is going to go down
in the next two years it's not
it's not
if it does call me and i'll buy your
house
it's not
okay
seriously but now if you want if you
just want the peace of mind go to the
bar
mark is hanging out with and tell all
the friends i was wrong i'll buy y'all
no i don't buy everybody in the bar's
house i'm not buying a round i'm just
buying his but it's just not going to
happen it's just not going to happen
okay
so you know you're okay you're okay
but if you want to sell it it's also
okay
you're not dumb for being 100 debt free
you're not dumb but i just don't want
you to make decisions based on fear
and and and feelings rather than data